the temperature of our favorite time of
the year the site of the landscape of
the environment we grew up in the taste
of a home-cooked meal the emotion of an
old song that we once listened to on
repeat for a month straight all of these
things elicit a feeling so unique and
powerful that it appears to transcend
time and space it brings us into a state
of being that cannot be described with
anything other than just this one word
it is nostalgia nostalgia is one of the
most unique and valuable capacities of
the human mind it is the closest thing
we have to time travel it gives us an
opportunity to experience moments of our
life while being completely free from
our normal anxieties and uncertainties
in general every moment in life carries
with it a set of fears anxieties and
stresses we are always concerned with
making the next moment perfect and we
worry about what tomorrow may or may not
bring but nostalgia frees us from this
when we experience nostalgia we are
given an opportunity to feel a moment as
it truly was void of any fear or
uncertainty this is because the
circumstances that we worried about at
the time have already passed at the time
our worries lied in the uncertainty of
what the next several days months or
years would bring but those days have
since passed we have lived through the
times that we were worried about and
here we are doing just fine ironically
letting the state of nostalgia carry us
into the past can remind us of the
importance of appreciating the present
it shows us that our desire to perfect
all the moments of life is foolish and
unnecessary it shows us that our fears
and worries regarding the future are
irrational and insignificant and it
shows us that we are resilient and
adaptable and that no matter what life
throws at us we can sustain and continue
to create meaningful positive moments
nostalgia provides clarity in that even
the moments that may have been stressful
and did not seem so good at the time can
still carry a sense of great value and
appreciation when viewed through the
lens of hindsight this very moment in
time despite if there are things going
on that may seem negative or stressful
will likely still have a feeling of
nostalgia attached to it when you are
reminded of it in the future and if this
is true why not appreciate it right now
as well
[Music]
thank you for watching if you found
enjoyment and value in this video please
give it a thumbs up share your thoughts
in the comments below and if you are not
already be sure to subscribe to our
Channel we are constantly coming out
with new videos to help you experience
life with clarity and Wonder